We are ready for our first surprise guest
and I'm gonna give you some clues.
Okay.
Let's see how you will do.
He would be on your top 10 list of guests
I think you'd want at any party.
You once surprised him on his birthday.
Oh my God.
And his super human trick
David
was being one of the greatest television hosts
of all time.
Do you know who this might be?
I know exactly who it is.
Who is it?
David Letterman.
Let us welcome David Letterman.
Hi, Dave!
(audience applauding)
Everybody!
Hi, Drew!
Happy birthday!
Savannah, hello, how are you?
Hi!
She's dying, she can't believe it.
Oh my gosh.
I'm having a hard time
Can you hear me?
catching my breath.
I can hear you!
Dave!
I can't, I can't hear her.
Dave.
Is there a filter.
Wait.
Do you have a filter on?
I can't, tell her to unmute,
can you unmute?
Are you Zooming, Dave?
What's like,
Yeah.
are you good at technology?
I'm not a cat.
(laughing)
That is everywhere.
I can't,
I'm sorry I can't hear her.
Well, you look like a fine cat.
Can you hear me?
Okay, it's the thought that counts, Dave.
Yes, we can hear you.
We hear you, but can you hear us?
To heck with this.
(laughing)
Forget it, forget it.
Can you believe?
I think that's so sweet of him to do that.
I know.
When was the last time you actually saw Dave?
I feel the same way he does about Zoom.
Yeah.
Especially when my daughters crash it, so.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
♪ Party rock ♪
Hi everybody.
♪ Yeah ♪
How are you?
Hi, Savannah.
Hi, Dave.
How are you?
I'm coming there.
Hi.
You look wonderful.
Nice to see you, happy birthday!
(audience cheering)
What do you think?
Here, sit down.
Oh my.
(laughing)
We're gonna need the tissues.
Yeah.
I'm so grateful
that you came here.
Let me tell you something.
You know that a little trick with a computer and stuff,
that Zoomer thing, that was my idea.
That was good, you still got it.
Thank you.
It was really effective.
I really thought I was like, okay, yeah, you know Dave,
I get it too.
No, are you, you're actually crying.
Yeah.
Oh, that breaks my heart.
God bless you.
I'm, I'm so grateful that you are showing up for me,
I loved showing up for you.
Well, I can't,
I can't thank you enough for everything
and the friendship that you demonstrated for us when we were
on the show and it meant a great deal then
and this means a great deal as well.
Happy, happy birthday and thank you.
Thank you for, or did I invite myself?
No!
I don't know how
this happened.
You're the, you're this,
you're kind of the guest of honor next to Drew,
but wait--
The poor dear's actually crying.
She's crying, she's shocked.
I told her she really thought she might know who was coming.
I love you, I really do.
I love you as well.
Well, wait, hold on
because we want to hear everything.
We want to hear all of your stories.
We have to take a break, okay.
Will you stick with us.
Do I go back to the Zoom?
No.
(laughing)
Stay right here.
We're gonna have a lot more with Drew and Dave
when we come back.
(upbeat music)